una rusa sputnik se producirá en italia
el laboratorio suizo a quien alcanzó un
acuerdo con el fondo de inversión
directa ruso para desarrollar 10
millones de dosis en sus instalaciones
italianas a partir de julio un pacto que
según rusia facilitará el cumplimiento
de la demanda extranjera
en general las cadenas de producción se
están estableciendo en varios países a
la vez de muchas maneras esto ayudará a
satisfacer la creciente demanda del
mercado externo muy rápidamente
patrimonio minera
el líder del fondo ruso también informó
sobre presuntos acuerdos con españa
alemania y francia aunque desde el
ministerio de industria francés negaron
cualquier entendimiento
el pacto se da en medio de las tensiones
en torno a los análisis de la agencia
europea de medicamentos para la posible
autorización de la spu tikvá la
directora de la junta directiva de la
agencia crista virtud mar og calificó el
fármaco de ruleta rusa y anticipó que
falta información para aprobar los
dichos reprobados por moscú aún así tres
países de la unión europea ya la
aprobaron no están en ese proceso
hungría república checa y eslovaquia
cuatro gatos o joven jacob y lleve atrás
dado que la pandemia del cobi 19 no
presta atención a los problemas
geopolíticos y la protección de la vida
humana prevalece por encima de todo
hemos considerado oportuno comprar una
vacuna rusa para que los eslovacos que
lo deseen puedan vacunarse en machu
picchu hay brusco bucks y no es por la
cndh y buback sino la spu tikvá ya ha
sido registrada en 45 naciones siendo la
segunda vacuna más respaldada por las
agencias reguladoras en el mundo